there has been a very underreported  phenomenon of left Wingers vandalizing  burning spring graffiti on pro-life  pregnancy centers the libs have not  answered for this it's awful I mean  that's an attack on some of the most  vulnerable women and poor little babies  that you could possibly imagine and  these absolute demons are running around  perpetrating these crimes so finally a  reporter asked White House Press  Secretary Kareem Jean-Pierre about it  here's her answer in the meantime like  Pro pregnancy centers are being attacked  it is just it that is just not something  that uh that I'm going to comment from  here about what the former president  said uh it is you know uh just not going  to get any further again I'm just not  going to get any further I'm just not  going to comment about that because I  want it to keep happening that's what  they're saying